avant d'ouvrir, j'explore juste avec vous
deux alpha alpha comme si les étudiants
sortaient de l'oxymétrie bleue 1500, donc
nous devons y arriver avant que je ne dise d'accord,
c'est une bonne vitesse pour vous ouais ouais ouais une
bonne vitesse sur l'oxydant garde 900 et vous
avez  trafic supplémentaire juste beaucoup j'ai eu du
trafic hors de savoir ce que des milliers de vous
disent ouais le premier numéro deux est
six
il s'agit de matraquer comme 10 secondes bien
heureusement chronique d'un œil
qui était là
aussi gardez-le comme ça ça se passe
quoi d'autre  nous sommes arrivés vous
continuez un peu mais l'inclinaison vers le haut peut-être
un rythme agile d'accord
monocle courage Time Square Enix répondez
Yeti puis ouvrez le capitaine un oui faites-moi
savoir ce que vous voulez
bien nous allons jouer à droite oh
vraiment que diriez-vous d'une gauche  et puis à droite
ok ouais bon ouais ouais en tournant
juste un peu à gauche et
j'attends à droite copain bop
à droite je le fais en pensant en
fait tu vas aller 180 vers la
droite comme 10 20 pour  le droit
peut-être même t  o 20 avec prédicateur est-ce par
produit par ces arbres dans le
parc central et encore une autre ligne que je suis
des pinces carrées Ian ça va monter cette
route qui va à gauche des arbres
vivre pour cette gauche ça va plus loin en
riant voir un  va juste à côté d'eux
et on va plus loin au Lafayette
voir il y a un bâtiment vert n'aidant aucun
trimestre la courte année c'est juste à propos de
l'arrivée alors lequel d'accord maintenant vous voyez
il y a comme on va bien ouais
nous contournons la façon dont nous nous sommes disputés
flèche un veux partager même ombre droite
une nuit hôtel Roger Roger le trafic
a traversé alors nous entrerons dans le
même temps avec un peu de plaisir prenez le
bouton les garçons que je mettrais en vedette dans un film est
proche de votre cœur c'est le moment de  paire
est-il
temps un peu plus loin, vous verrez
commencer à voir la lumière se refléter sur les
bâtiments pour effectuer ou contacter le radar à
trois milles ce sont des points rois à
1400 ça va être là
j'ai été un peu à droite ici
ouais
à  fois là-haut attends attends tu b  e
patient d'accord nous allons presque
y arriver c'est là que cette lumière est venue dans la
rue est-ce loin cette industrie ouais
cette chose est quelque chose ouais vous ne voyez pas
vraiment bien un peu d'un Shetty
Shetty toute la ville entière ouais  nous faisons un
fragment de bâtiment avec le ciel qu'est-ce que tu
veux dire par nous regardons horizontalement ouais d'
accord alors pouvons-nous faire demi-tour vers la droite dans
quelle direction voulez-vous aller alors étudiez
mieux d'aller à la jambe sans rien faire d'accord
mettez le soleil derrière nous là assez  d'accord,
je veux avoir Empire ou Chrysler juste
derrière ouais ouais ouais oui s'il vous plaît,
tournez la caméra vers la tête,
ils ne lui parleront pas quand nous
aurons dépassé le toit, légitimes les joueurs que je
dis
pour parler de l'argent du trafic  Lincoln
Tunnel pour consacrer ce travail bleu là-
bas aujourd'hui un autre j'ai deux pouces trois
pouces un support de division charnu Corinthe
acrylique vérifier ici camion probable 11
la merde viens sur la station hélicoptère 1500
sécurité Robert lanceur le système un
cri VFR peut-être si je loo  k à l'
entreprise je pensais un peu au sud-ouest de
l'Empire
ouais ça volera directeur chez Empire et
Chrysler ouais
avril qui est celui avec l'
or II mis dessus qui serait
Chrysler directement hors de votre
pied gauche mais maintenant avec le petit  un
des bâtiments les plus beaux ouais je vais faire top
ouais il y en a un qui est un peu comme
ouais tu ne peux pas vraiment le voir sur le plan
si tu ne sais pas ce qui est bien c'est comme un
village ouais juste le coin deux milles
hélicoptère  à 16h00, il n'y a pas de trafic pour
parler, c'est sur toute la longueur du nord, un
arrêt sur je me sentirai justifié
comme si c'était le cas, prenons le temps mort,
puis ils filment en train de devenir
un peu zippe Je vais voler juste à
côté de vous s'il vous plaît dites  vous ce que je vais faire
je volerai vers eux je passerai le
côté nord de l'empire ouais hé allons y
le côté sud de l'empire je ne peux pas
bien dormir je suis sur le trafic à la
bouche du Lincoln Tunnel  le
mainteneur de Roger en direction du nord maintenant à
tout le monde depuis votre ech  o Golf Buddy c'est
nos 15 applaudissements out of blue 1500
symétrie zéro zéro directeur Niner bonjour
pas de problèmes l'expression de défense d'actualité
impliquant une fonctionnalité dans un système
est par peur car
je pense que nous souhaitons peut-être l'obtenir nous avons
ses points de la radio un téléviseur convient
mieux d'accord je vais beaucoup mieux d'accord d'
accord on achète beaucoup prendre ce coup ici
on peut le refaire
oh il suffit d'aller un peu plus au sud ouais de
se transformer en viol en allant à droite je suis
un recadrage que mon truc enregistreur
chahute tout /  et regardez mec, nous vous avons fait
traverser vers le sud, nous faisons une
vidéo Le
golf de Jericho leur sort huit à l'
improviste neuf cents la
fonction de progression dans l'assistance et une peur de crier car
je pourrais revenir en arrière voyons jusqu'où
nous devons aller au sud  si nous pouvons le battre
d'ici
pour offrir de l'or est prêt pour le voyage
jusqu'à l'excision de notre personnel enseignant
impliquez un assistant spécial de peur car
c'est bien
bon rouler d'accord
faites un peu de cercle autour de nous dans des
tartes et puis  retourner au  pont ouais
hé je suis un américain je viens de bien manger donne
moi environ un stand un peu plus large et puis
moi changer manger léger contre
éternel si aller au
pont monter lentement 22 notre New York sept gros
en 48 heures New York 707 pour Delta oui
New York seven store Delta New York
seven squawk to2015 l'interprète pour
Delta little 1500 certains des arbres ici
zéro Niner trois zéro zéro Niner
squawkin zéro deux zéro un et 1500 pour
l'Empire de New York tout le chemin vers le
côté gauche de l'écran à venir  maintenant
vous savez que chaque rocher sur le tacle a toujours fière
allure Je ne sais pas non plus que je me sens
heureux à 1000 maintenant
et l'hélicoptère de la terreur de la liberté vers l'alpha l'
a
bien fait ouais
cet endroit partout
mais je suis préoccupé par les gens
là-bas je pense envoyé pas à  survolez
ce concert
où est le concert d'une heure dans
l'herbe du grand nord bleu euh eh bien
maintenant juste au nord de celui-ci Pâques
bon d'accord
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ce sont des
coupures au sommet du bâtiment
c'est le club
c'est mon  le camion
continue l'essai de vous dire que le
bâtiment de cristal disparaît
oh ouais la merde a ça d'accord je suppose
un plus simple avec Empire ouais les gars
et je suppose que c'est un peu ouais
vous savez que nous arrivons du côté ouest et
qu'est-ce qui en rapprochera bien
il n'y a pas vraiment beaucoup de monde dans
les rues aujourd'hui
c'est trop beau été un peu tard l'automne
mais beaucoup de gens dans les rues
le samedi se promènent
ouais s'il n'y a pas 0,42 son
sujet de physique au-dessus bleu saphir de Ceylan 1500
sevilla trees  le vôtre vos pièges mineurs
parlent d'un flop après que voici 1 000
individus 0,5 ou moins crache lâcher le
producteur d'attirer sur
le pont George Washington s'arrêter après que
8900 Isuzu sur Photoshop si je maintiens un
visuel et vérifie le GW c'est
la loi pour  Roger, il ne peut pas exclure
un autre problème, le système est clair
car il va être pour offrir une
belle apparence oui je
oh nous avons le fusil de chasse de toute façon ouais USA
pense à quelle bataille de zoo - tu vois
tous les autres t  hings ouais voir les sketchs
mais euh tu veux aller juste là
sur Wall Street à Ground Zero où
sont-ils pertinents
J'ai laissé mon coup maintenant plus à droite
c'est le côté sud-est d'une île
ouais avec Grantham
juste devant nous Sanga be  bien aller comme
ça de toute façon ouais en pensant que ça va
aller le plaidoyer voudriez-vous euh ouais
je vous dis ce qu'ils regardent de haut en
écrivant est que vous voulez juste tirer sur le
centre-ville ici et ensuite tout cela dans la
rivière vous pouvez en descendre plusieurs
des sources observent que votre une heure
et à quelques kilomètres de la ville ont découvert que les
jeunes indiquent un tableau de mille
centrales électriques de tissage appelées fermes de peur
pour changer l'auvent approuvé de cette façon,
il est un moyen d'atteindre le point zéro sans
ombre
attendons-nous un  peu ou voulez-vous ramer d'
accord je vais regarder dans quelle
surprise vous êtes et nous cherchons
bien super merci
fenêtre dm7 on pourrait vous trouver rapidement
examen informel à
droite